[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
tanzen um den krieg zu vergessen er
flüchtete ukrainische balletttänzerinnen
können am theater basel ihrer
leidenschaft weiterhin nachgehen eine
zeit der kontraste und der
verunsicherung
der russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine hat gezeigt frieden und
wohlstand in europa sind nicht
selbstverständlich
was bedeutet das für westliche
demokratien
kulturplatz sucht wege des umgangs mit
dieser zeitenwende
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja hier
drüben in der st jakobshalle es zurzeit
die ballettschule des theaters basel
untergebracht und seit kurzem trainieren
hier auch junge tänzerinnen aus der
ukraine
vor zwei wochen ist ihnen die flucht aus
der heimat gelungen und auch sie allein
hat bereits über das schicksal der 16
jährigen mädchen berichtet
ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können dass
so etwas möglich ist ich stand unter
schock und ich konnte es nicht glauben
nun bin ich so dankbar dass ich meinem
traum weiterhin nachgehen kann
denn als in der ukraine der krieg
losbrach dachte ich mein traum vom
tanzen wäre gestohlen worden
hier treffen sie hier in basel sprechen
über den krieg in ihrer heimat und über
das glück weiter tanzen zu können in
sicherheit zu sein
[Musik]
ja und wir fragen was dieser krieg für
uns alle bedeutet von einer zeitenwende
ist die rede ist es also vorbei mit dem
gefühl von sicherheit und wie geht
überhaupt frieden große fragen
das was gerade in der ukraine passiert
was wir alle erleben
wird unser dasein für immer bestimmen
aber nicht nur unseres
das frei tfg nebelo rositz die
ukrainische schriftstellerin und
fotokünstlerin in ihrem kriegstagebuch
das zurzeit international publiziert
wird seit einem monat erzählt sie wie
sie mit dem krieg lebt von tag zu tag
wie leben wir hier in europa mit dem
krieg den wir im internet ziehen im
fernsehen in der zeitung
wird er unser leben verändern müsste er
ich glaube schon dass es für uns ein
wirkliche veränderung sein könnte
denn nichts wirklich die pessimistische
generell ein optimist aber dass das
jetzt noch hinzu fernanda und und mehr
und immer noch thema unterschwellig
laufen im wald das flugzeug ihnen und
ich das gefühl jetzt haben wir einen
punkt erreicht wo mir ein neues normal
kreieren
man hört immer neue normalität aber man
hält den atem an und das wasser steigt
und steigt es fühlt sich nicht so an als
ob es nach lässt alle sagen jetzt kommt
die normalität zurück das wird auf aber
masken pflicht vorbei da ist der krieg
was kommt als nächstes
es gibt einfach keine pause mehr
ich denke ich dass wir also das jetzt
irgend eine art normalität zurückkommen
wird ich mir auch vorstellen dass das
eigentlich das potenzial
ein
veränderung birgt
ist das nun die zeitenwende von der
aktuell so oft die rede ist machen wir
den krieg zum ausgangspunkt für etwas
neues
was tun
gewichtige besonnene stimmen hören
carolin emcke ist reine die philosophin
die lange als kriegsreporterin für den
spiegel und die zeit unterwegs war
dieser tage hat sie ihr neues buch in
der schweiz vorgestellt für mich ist es
eben nicht der erste krieg in europa es
gab schon erste brände zwar in bosnien
es gab überhaupt die ganzen gewalt
farbigen konflikte im ehemaligen
jugoslawien
das ist eher erschütternd oder
erschreckend wie schnell das in
vergessenheit geraten ist dass es das
schon gab
aber die brutalität dieses krieges
die
[Musik]
unsicherheit über die entgrenzung dieses
krieges
und das heißt eben die unsicherheit wie
weit er sich noch nach europa hinein
verlagert oder ausweitet das ist
sicherlich eine zäsur
wir konnten uns nicht mehr vorstellen
dass gewalt ein mittel der
konfliktlösung ist
im westen haben wir uns mit ähnlichen
themen beschäftigt klimaschutz
nachhaltigkeit gerechtigkeit
doch der slogan nie wieder krieg wer hat
nicht funktioniert
nun sehen wir überall
kampf
soldaten
köpfe helden europa rüstet auf scheinbar
alternativlos sind die themen die uns
jahrelang beschäftigt haben und schnee
von gestern
ich glaube dass die klimafrage und eben
auch die frage der
sicherheitsrelevanten struktur der
energie
eine ist die
central verkuppelt ist mit diesem krieg
und ich glaube
dass wir diese krisen zusammen denken
müssen und dass nicht der krieg die
anderen fragen überfordert oder
überschatten darf das wäre glaube ich
fatal
die krisen kommen nicht mehr einzeln sie
verstärken sich gegenseitig und sie
werden so bald nicht enden
die klimabewegung erwacht aus dem chor
ohne schlaf und steht im zeichen der
solidarität mit der ukraine
kann diese zeit eine chance sein zu
verstehen wie versteckt unser wohlstand
mit putins krieg ist ich glaube dass man
krisen als chance betrachten neben einer
sehr privilegierten sich diese aber
natürlich gewisse krisen auch chancen
sind missstand wie das mikro atx ist
aber natürlich habe die finanzkrise 0800
ölkrise im letzten jahrhundert und
wieder mit dem krieg und
krisen ist realistischer interesse und
ich glaube das weckt oder erreicht immer
mehr manche logischen visum entdeckt und
dass wir da immer klarer dass ökologie
und
der kantine
vielleicht heißt seitenwände einfach wir
erwachen in einer realität sind hier
wäre schon längst waren
[Musik]
sind jetzt immer noch einen punkt wo
alles sich pariert und das ist der grund
wieso ich da bin und demonstrierte klima
energie
das ist eigentlich eine doppelte und in
sich sehr logisch ich
bin ich bin nicht überrascht dass es
nicht mehr geht und wo die dämmerung
verstört zwischen der erdölabhängigkeit
wo ist eine klimakrise nina kriegt er
hat schon jetzt wo noch viel schlimmer
wird und aber auch die abhängigkeit von
uns
[Musik]
jewgenia beloruss sets schreibt aus kiew
ich kann die augen nicht schließen
findet keine ruhe und darüber will ich
erzählen morgen früh werde ich diesen
text wieder lesen
wenn ich ihn noch lesen werde bedeutet
es dass wir diese nacht überlebt haben
nicht nur der blutige krieg gegen die
ukraine putin kämpft gegen demokratie
und freiheitliche werte in moskau und
sankt petersburg bringt vor allem junge
menschen riesigen mut drauf gehen auf
die straße und beziehen stellung gegen
den krieg und riskieren hohe strafen
[Musik]
was tun
der autor und dichter alexander es dies
ist russe mit ukrainisch jüdischem
hintergrund seit jahren lebt er in der
schweiz seit kriegsbeginn findet er
keine ruhe schreibt wo immer es geht
über menschen wie die theatermacherin
marina dawydowa sie hat eine petition
gegen den krieg verfasst wurde zum opfer
der kriegstreiber musste inzwischen der
land verlassen gefilmt von
überwachungskameras
leute wieder wiederwahl stehen für ein
anderes russland
dieses andere russland ins bewusstsein
zu heben sowohl hier als auch von sich
aus sozusagen
gespiegelt wieder zurück ins
geografische russland dieses eigentliche
andere russland präsent zu halten und
als ein
ideal zu etablieren auch dass man
hinarbeiten kann das ist denke ich eine
würdige und enorm wichtige aufgabe im
moment
diese woche hat die letzte
kremlkritische zeitung nowaja gaseta
erscheinen eingestellt die
meinungsfreiheit in russland ist
endgültig beseitigt nur in den sozialen
netzwerken vor allem auf telegramm wird
noch widerspruch sichtbar alexander ist
es wünscht sich dass der westen mit der
opposition russischsprachige sender
aufbaut diese könnten nach russland
zurück wirken und so vielleicht die
kraft haben putins staat zu erschüttern
man muss bei denjenigen ansätzen die
hier sind und jetzt auch zunehmend
hierher kommen denn es gibt ja eine
enorme fluchtbewegung im moment aus
russland alle möglichen oppositionell
eingestellten kräfte kommen jetzt
nach westen weil sie sich gefährdet
sehen und diese menschen hier
einzubinden ist der erste schritt denn
sie haben die innenperspektive die hier
einfach zählt
es gebe viel zu tun denn unsere
freiheitliche lebensweise ist bedroht
jetzt besteht die gefahr dass wir uns
allmählich an den krieg in der ukraine
gewöhnen
wir beginnen uns schon zu fragen wie
viele bilder wir vom krieg vertragen
wie resilient jeder und jede von uns ist
[Musik]
natürlich wird jetzt gefragt was braucht
es eben an an psychischen dispositionen
auch um
ja den schrecken und das grauen dieser
bilder zu verkraften das ist auch alles
richtig ich würde es keineswegs
abwertend aber ich glaube die frage nach
der resilienz ist eine die wir als
gesellschaft
beantworten müssen und die wir als
demokratische gesellschaften beantworten
müssen wir müssen alles tun um die
demokratie gegen ihre feinde zu
verteidigen
es braucht verantwortung und die
bereitschaft nicht einfach genauso
weiterzumachen nur so gelingt eine echte
zeitenwende
eines ist sicher
die menschen in der ukraine verteidigen
die freiheit auch in unserem namen ihre
tagebücher zu lesen wäre etwas das man
tun kann und nicht wieder ein zu
schlummern das von evgenia beloruss es
beginnt zu der krieg hat begonnen es ist
mitternacht ich werde wohl kaum
einschlafen können und es hat keinen
sinn aufzuzählen was sich für immer
verändert hat
[Musik]
olesja sofia maria
leistung so schön euch zu sehen wie geht
es euch ihr seid jetzt seit zwei wochen
hier in basel wie ist die situation
wir sind so glücklich hier sein zu
dürfen
natürlich ist der grund für unseren
aufenthalt sehr traurig angesichts der
lage in der ukraine
aber wir sind sehr dankbar dass wir
weiter tanzen dürfen
was bedeutet euch das tanzen in diesen
tagen ich kann mir vorstellen das ist
sehr wichtig
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir weiter
tanzen können und es hilft zu vergessen
was in unserer heimat passiert
schafft ihr es euch einen moment nur auf
das tanzen zu konzentrieren ist das
möglich
ja ich denke schon das ist wichtig
beim ballett training kann man alles
ausbleiben hintern man muss sehr
konzentriert sein
wo sind denn eure familien sind sie hier
meine ganze familie ist noch in der
ukraine sie sind zwar nicht in ihrer
heimatstadt aber in sicherheit
mein vater ist in der ukraine weil
männer ja das land nicht verlassen
dürfen aber meine mutter und meine
schwester sind ebenfalls in sicherheit
in europa aber du hörst deinen vater du
kannst mit ihnen telefonieren ja klar
wir sprechen jeden tag zusammen
für dich dass du weiter tanzen kannst
natürlicher
und ist dann die situation mit euren
neuen kolleginnen hier
es ist sehr gut alle sind sehr nett hier
das hoffe ich
wenn wen welche fragen haben helfen sie
uns immer
wieso tanzt ihr welche bedeutung hat es
für euer leben tanzen bedeutet leben für
mich ist der tanz ein weg meine
emotionen auszudrücken und durch die
bewegung anderen menschen mitzuteilen
wenn ich auf der straße bin bin ich eine
normale person aber wenn ich ins
ballettstudio gehe kann ich so viele
gefühle ausdrücken und mich auf
besondere art zum ausdruck bringen
auf der bühne kann ich jedes mal in ein
anderes leben schlüpfen und diese
anderen leben wechseln von stück zu
stück
es ist sie eine sprache
ballett ist definitiv eine sprache ein
großes danke und alles alles gute für
familien danke
[Musik]
die was wäre wenn fragen haben
hochkonjunktur in diesen tagen und
momentan fragen viele hätte dieser krieg
in der ukraine verhindert werden können
mit anderen diplomatischen mitteln will
heißen mit weiblicheren mitteln unser
stichwort der stunde heißt feministische
außenpolitik
ein neuer begriff hält einzug auf dem
politischen parkett
letzter woche ein heiß diskutiertes
thema im deutschen bundestag
sie können von hier aus feministischer
außenpolitik machen feministische
entwicklungshilfepolitik das können sie
alles machen aber nicht mit diesem etat
für die bundeswehr
die bundeswehr hinzustellen und dann im
gleichen satz zu sagen okay bundeswehr
und nicht mehr diese feministische
außenpolitik mir bricht es das herz und
deswegen gehört zu einer
sicherheitspolitik des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert auch eine feministische
nicht
tatsächlich ist feministische
außenpolitik kein gedöns mehr in london
und berlin gibt es zentren für
feministische außenpolitik immer mehr
literatur erscheint zum thema kürzlich
ein buch mit dem selbstbewussten titel
die zukunft der außenpolitik ist
feministisch und auch in der schweiz ist
das thema angekommen
die feministische politik selbstwert
ruft das manöver sache fördert wir
sprach empathie
die ganze diplomatie und den
multilateralismus
klare regeln wie es fällt also alle die
jetzt im moment unklar sind infrage
gestellt werden
[Musik]
feministische außenpolitik priorisiert
menschenrechte statt militarisierung
sorgt für schutz und sicherheit aller
menschen
bekämpft patriarchale strukturen
die politikwissenschaftlerin lernt rabbi
us forscht für das friedens instituts
whiskies hätte der krieg in der ukraine
durch feministische außenpolitik
verhindert werden können
haben die kriege auf der welt also mit
dem patriarchat zu tun liegt es an
toxischer männlichkeit wenn sich ein
staatsoberhaupt entscheidet ein
souveränes land zu überfallen oder
würden frauen wenn sie an der macht
wären genauso skrupellos truppen in den
krieg schicken
man erinnere sich etwa in die ehemalige
britische premierministerin margaret
thatcher genannt die eiserne lady die
britische truppen 1982 auf die falkland
inseln in den krieg gegen argentinien
schickte
oder auch die kürzlich verstorbene
madeleine albright die erste
außenministerin der usa die in den 90er
jahren ein todbringendes embargo im irak
gutgeheissen hatte
zudem war albright während des
kosovo-krieges ende der 90er jahre die
treibende kraft bei der nato
bombardierung serbiens
monate putzfrau sie gut versorgt als
absoluter vorteil schnell wegwill
eines it titel in der flak existiert das
aber durchaus erfreulich und gewalttätig
sie und männer genauso auch verwundbar
sind das eigentlich vor der zweiteilige
frau als opfer als täter die sich selbst
aktiv und es verhindert dass wir
gesamtgesellschaftlich realisiert was
ich esse stehen wo pro mann und frau
regierungen und ideen verhaltens wie es
drängt und das ist unter anderem über
die botschaft ist klar es spielt keine
rolle ob ein mann oder eine frau die
geschicke einer nation lenkt so lange
patriarchale strukturen existieren wird
es zu kriegen kommen das sei der
hauptgrund warum es nicht humanistische
sondern eben feministische außenpolitik
heißt trotzdem angesichts der aktuellen
lage in der ukraine kommt die forderung
nach vermin ist ischer außenpolitik doch
etwas blauäugig daher kann sie etwas
gegen despoten wie bouzid ausrichten
präventiv also sieht viel früher ins aus
setzte also mit flug und umwelt okay die
hand fragen oft nato konzentriert
anstatt duft osze organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
dann hätte die kleine investieren was er
diplomatisch sie hätte keine show bieten
in version von georg ganz andere
sanktionen erheben und so viel früher
eine linie ziehen anstatt jetzt schon
völlig eskaliert hat also viel früher
oft menschenrechte geworden
es geht um prävention sowie
friedensverhandlungen studien zeigen je
mehr frauen offiziell am
friedensabkommen beteiligt waren desto
länger kam es zu keinem bewaffneten
konflikt den frauen stelle in kriegen
einen großteil der zivilbevölkerung
deshalb sei ihre stimme bei
friedensverhandlungen unverzichtbar die
uno hat bereits im jahr 2000 eine
friedens resolution geschaffen in der es
um den schutz von frauen in kriegen und
deren teilhabe an friedensprozessen geht
die weichen sind eigentlich gestellt für
lerntherapie us geht es um ein
grundsätzliches umdenken was ich
sicherheit für weltpriester
definition um sicherheit bedeutet in
allererster linie staatliche in
territoriale integrität
sollen aber auf schutz für das
individuum im alltag schutz im sinn
vorne nur keiner gewalt ausgesetzt
werden wir sie definieren sondern bald
etwas feministischer perspektive wo auch
strukturelle diskriminierung beinhaltet
und jegliche verletzung von
menschenrechten also fokus weg vom staat
hier zu jeder mensch und zum schutz der
mannschaft vor
diplomatie statt kampf in zeiten des
krieges kann man die forderung nach
feministische außenpolitik entweder
deplatziert finden oder aber dringend
notwendig um sie herum kommt man wohl
nicht mehr
[Musik]
wir fragen aus nächstes wie viele
russisches geld steckt in der schweizer
kultur eines ist klar der umgang mit
fragwürdigen kultur fördern muss neu
gedacht werden
von genf bis zug von luzern bis sankt
moritz
russlands finanzchefs enthält der
schweiz seit jahrzehnten die treue
darunter so klingende namen wie suleiman
kerimov viktor wechselberg oder gennadi
timtschenko
gemeinsam haben sie nicht nur ihre enge
verbindung zu bleiben putin sondern auch
eine gewisse spendierfreudigkeit wenn es
um schweizer kultur geht ihr geld und
das andere landsmänner flossen der
vergangenheit den festivals wie baby
pause in luzern oder das comicfestival 5
die betroffenen betreiber hätten
spätestens seit der russischen ukraine
invasion die kooperation aufgekündigt
heißt es und gelder zurückgezahlt
darüber hinaus gäbe es kein kommentar
wie also findet man heraus welche rolle
russisches geld auf die schweizer kultur
markt spielt an der zürcher hochschule
der künste treffen wir christoph beck
halle von den civic creative economy
droht jetzt gar eine finanzielle
schieflage
ich würde behaupten dass wir in der
schweiz seien ein sehr robustes system
haben die staatliche grundversorgung
delegierten wo vielleicht beim 80
prozent und dann nachher gibt es
sicherlich mehr wie 10% er gegen 20
prozent
private mittel die in den kulturellen
sektor hieß
von diesen privaten mitteln stammt
wiederum nur ein kleiner teil von
russischen geldgeber und diese
investieren vor allem in branchen von
denen sie sich sichtbar kreta hoffen wie
beispielsweise das zurich film festival
das bis 2017 ebenfalls russische
fördergelder bekommen hat
und da würde ich jetzt meinen
sind besonders interessant
branchen sparten events muss um glamour
geht bloß einen roten teppich gibt wo es
etwas schein ist wo ich meinen namen ins
spiel bringen kann indem ich darauf
hinarbeiten dass ich ein bisschen
unsterblich werden
es geht also um vermächtnis um ansehen
sagt weckerlin
virtuell verabreden wir uns mit einer
expertin in sachen reiche mussten die
soziologin elisabeth förster faust in
london zu oligarchen erwarten diese
nicht auch rendite von ihren engagements
im schweizer kultur markt
insgesamt wichtiger ist ist es
vielleicht ob die und kunstbereich
insgesamt als das eintrittsticket in
eine westliche aber klar seine
oberschicht in die gute gesellschaft
deines landes
diese gute gesellschaft trifft sich
gerne bei der alljährlichen ort basis
einer der bedeutendsten kunstmessen
weltweit hier geht es um große kunst und
nicht selten auch um großes geld
aufgrund der sanktionen werden die
russischen superreichen dieses jahr als
potenzielle käufer wohl vielen
andreas ritter ist vertreter der kunst
handelsverbände in der schweiz das durch
die ausbleibenden russen jetzt sozusagen
eine zäsur im kunstmarkt stattfindet
glaubt er nicht
die russen werden jetzt keine lücke
hinterlassen der kunstmarkt heute ist
derart international die sie haben
gesehen die messe in basel hat auch
jetzt im es in paris übernommen hat
ausrichtungen in hongkong in miami so
wird beispielsweise ein sichern exter
sogenannter hotspot werken und da spielt
die musik und das ist international und
da kommt auf die russischen oligarchen
nicht drauf waren
insgesamt werden im schweizer
kunsthandel jedes jahr bis zu einer
milliarde franken umgesetzt
immerhin der fünftgrößte kunstmarkt der
welt
bietet er damit auch ein geeignetes
umfeld für kapitalanlagen oder gar für
geldwäsche
das sieht der blonden sein geld mit
weniger aufmerksamkeit zu waschen
fazit russisches geld spielt im
schweizer kunst und kultur markt nur
eine nebenrolle
abhängigkeiten gibt es kaum doch in
zukunft wird in sachen geld wohl noch
genauer hingeschaut
[Musik]
das war unser besuchern der
ballettschule des theaters basel
wie gehen wir um mit einem krieg in der
ukraine wie sprechen wir etwa mit
unseren kindern über krieg sich so
existenzielle fragen zu stellen das
steht tatsächlich für so etwas wie eine
zeitenwende im ganz privaten auch und
umso wichtiger sind dafür momente der
entspannung zum beispiel im wald und in
den wald dann nehme ich sie nächste
woche mit gleich jetzt folgt die
sternstunde philosophie hier auf sf1 mit
dem geheimnis der freiheit kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
ist reese los